[Applaudissements]
présidente madame la Première ministre
hier vous avez été défait vous et tous
les semeurs de haine hier votre loi
immigration a été batue par l'assemblée
du jamais vu en 25 ans hier nous sommes
fiers d'avoir épargné au pays de
semaines de déchaînement de paroles
racistes et xénophobes celles qui
divisent le peuple celles qui permettent
les passages à l'acte de la tentative
d'égorgement de mourade aux expéditions
punitives racistes à roman sur iser hier
comme demain nous serons toujours les
gardiens de l'unité du peuple hier nous
sommes fiers de vous avoir rappelé que
la France n'a jamais été une nation
ethnique mais sera toujours une nation
politique fondée sur la promesse liberté
égalité
fraternité hier vous avez été défait
après un président élu par défaut une
premierère ministre sans confiance vous
voilà à la tête d'un gouvernement
minoritaire sans légitimité
parlementaire ni populaire hier votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur a osé parler de
dénis de démocratie le dénis de
démocratie c'est vous
2493 2 ans de vie voler au français
contre l'immense majorité du peuple
madame la Première ministre 1493 vous
n'êtes rien si ce n'est un gouvernement
incapable incapable de légiférer et de
gouverner hier vous avez osé dire que
l'assemblée c'était déshonoré et ne
représentit pas les Français mais les
Français veulent des augmentations de
salaire une vérit politique contre la
vie chère des services publics qui
assurent l'égalité des citoyens ils
veulent en finir avec un gouvernement
qui a fait régresser la France à l'état
d'un pays qui a faim dans toutes les
démocraties quand un ministre est battu
il doit démissionner dans toutes les
démocraties quand la représentation
nationale rejette un texte il est retiré
madame la Première ministre sentez-vous
cette odeur de fin de règne tôt ou tard
vous serez contraint de retourner aux
urnes le peuple devra alors choisir
entre le camp des élites racistes ou
celui de l'Union Populaire madame la
Première ministre partez le plus vite
possible merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente votre temps est
écoulé la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Mathilde
Panau hier une fois de plus vous vous
êtes coalisé avec le rassemblement
national
hier hier une fois de plus vous avez
fait le choix délibéré de la
compromission avec l'extrême
droite vous qui souhaitez l'immigration
vous qui souhaitez l'immigration sans
règle vous
avez avec des partisans de l'imigration
zé vous qui souhaitez des
régularisations MIVE vous avez voté avec
ceux qui prôent la fermeture des
frontières et pour quel résultat madame
la Présidente panneau malgré vos
tentatives d'empêcher la discussion le
débat parlementaire va se poursuivre une
commission mixte paritaire va être va
être convoqué malgré vos tentatives pour
empêcher le débat nous ne renoncerons
pas à apporter des mesures fortes pour
nos
concitoyens vous plaît je pense que
définitivement le débat ça n'est pas
pour vous
alors madame la Présidente panneau
hormis quelques
[Applaudissements]
secondes non mais vous êtes fâché avec
la démocratie madame la Présidente Panau
et votre groupe
avec alors madame la Présidente
panelques satisfaction à l'Assemblée et
quelques minutes d'attention dans les
médias qu'avez-vous obtenu finalement
madame la Présidente panneau par votre
attitude et celle de votre groupe ceux
qui sont pénalisés ce sont les Français
les Français qui soutiennent très
largement notre
texte les Français qui attendent que
nous prenions des mesures fortes pour
réduire l'immigration illégale et pour
mieux intégrer les personnes que nous
choisissons d'accueillir les Français
qui veulent que nous trouvions des
compromis pas des coups politiques à la
petite semaine mais vous que leur
proposez-vous vous ne leur proposez que
le blocage de nos institutions vous ne
leur proposez qu'une union sacrée entre
la nupes et l'extrême droite vous ne le
proposez que le chaos c'est
irresponsable c'est dangereux et avec le
ministre géraldanin et tout V
gouvernement nous choisirons toujours le
chemin de l'action et de la
responsabilité au service des Français
je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première
ministre